So, in the whole computational photography pipeline,
what we're interested in is finding interesting features within an image.
So far, we've looked at point processes and convolutions.
Now, what we want to actually start doing is building on these concepts,
find interesting features in an image that would be matchable across
different images.
For that purpose, building on concepts of point processes and
neighborhood computation on an image, I'm going to introduce the whole
concept of image gradients, which basically says that at any point in an image,
where is the likelier direction of change?
And using that, we will be extracting things like edges and
other features that we'll talk about next.
But, in this one,
I'm going to actually use the whole concepts of convolution and
cross-correlation to introduce you the concept of how we
can do processing on an image, to compute image gradients.